[Music]
foreign
[Music]
he was hit by a truck and he was lying
out in that gut or dying and you had
time to sing one song
one song people would remember before
your dirt
one song that would let God know what
you felt about your time here on Earth
one song that would sum you up you
telling me that's the song you'd sing
get ready for a fresh new sound with
tonight's headliner our list of the best
music biopics music has been a crucial
component of the movies since the very
beginning back even when they were
supposedly silent so naturally we
started making movies about those makers
of Melodies I mean you you need watching
out for him he ain't got the time to
look after you the way I've been looking
is that what you've been doing I see
watching out for me is that why you get
paid double what I do and actors love
playing them they get to show off an
expanded range of talent and so many
musicians lives are filled with drama
and passion as the term implies the
biopics on this list are all based on
real people across an expanse of styles
Rock country hip-hop pop classical and
Beyond The Only Exception we made was
for eight mile though the names were
changed the fact that the main care
character a Marshall Mathers stand-in
was played by the original Marshall
Mathers demanded its inclusion you're
gonna let me borrow your car
nope
it's your birthday present
my birthday's not for two weeks
I know
still my little rabbit
after that
movie with a fresh rating is sorted by
adjusted to manometer to give us a
definitive ranking of the best movies
made about musicians let's take it from
the top and this time with feeling we're
counting down the best music biopics
foreign
[Music]
legendary Soul musician Ray Charles is
portrayed by Jamie Foxx in this
oscar-winning biopic young Rey watches
his seven-year-old brother drown at age
seven when he loses his sight at the age
of nine his hard-working mother urges
him not to feel sorry for himself he
rises through the ranks of the Seattle
Jazz scene struggling with drug
addiction and infidelity while on the
road supported by his wife Ray Charles
redefines Soul music and inspires a
generation starring Jamie Foxx Kerry
Washington Regina King and directed by
Taylor hackford critics say an
engrossing and energetic portrait of a
great musician's achievements and
foibles Rey is anchored by Jamie Foxx's
stunning performance as Ray Charles look
at the same time if you don't really
like the record you ain't got to beat
around the bush with me I mean my mama
never did
it's not that I don't enjoy your music
it's just that I feel I've heard it
before
I keep wondering what the real Ray
Charles sound like Ray Charles who's he
nobody if you don't know hmm
sorry I should have kept my mouth shut
oh no no then you wouldn't beat you
you know it's not like I haven't heard
that before I get sad to stop never
really listen that's all
ain't nobody ever put it that sweet I
guess
thank you
number nine La Bamba
Los Angeles teenager Richie Valens
becomes an overnight rock and roll
success in 1958. all of this was thanks
to a love ballad called Donna that he
wrote for his girlfriend whose parents
didn't want her to date a Latino boy but
as his star Rises Valance has conflicts
with his jealous brother Bob and becomes
haunted by a recurring nightmare of a
plane crash just as he begins his first
national tour alongside Buddy Holly
starring Lou Diamond Phillips esai
Morales Rosanna DeSoto and directed by
Luis Valdez critics say elevated by a
perceptive performance by a perfectly
cast Lou Diamond Phillips La Bamba
distills its subject's Creative Energy
and reflects his music's enduring appeal
I could tell him
sorry dude I didn't know that piece of
junk was so important to you are you
kidding I didn't sleep with
with no hope
come on
Jersey Jones Jersey talks
John Lewis
you okay oh are you okay can you move it
you all right
[Music]
you've grown Cameroon
you're a big sucker for 16. what's the
matter you miss me no
number eight Rocket Man
young Reginald Dwight changes his name
to Elton John and collaborates with
singer-songwriter Bernie toppin to
become one of the most iconic figures in
pop history set to his most beloved
songs it's the Epic musical story of
Elton John his breakthrough years in the
1970s and his Fantastical transformation
from shy piano Prodigy to International
Superstar starring Taryn Edgerton Jamie
Bell Richard Madden and directed by
Dexter Fletcher critics say it's gonna
be a long long time before a rock biopic
manages to capture the highs and lows of
an artist's life like Rocket Man
but the thing is
on
a homosexual
a puffeda
a fairy
Queen
say something
known for years
you don't mind frankly I don't care
I'd rather you keep that sort of thing
to yourself
I just hope you realize you're choosing
a life of being alone forever
you'll never be loved properly
right got to go
number seven Straight Outta Compton
in 1988 a groundbreaking new group
revolutionizes music and pop culture
changing and influencing hip-hop forever
nwa's first studio album Straight Out of
Compton stirs controversy with its
brutally honest depiction of life in
southern LA with guidance from veteran
manager Jerry Heller band members Ice
Cube Dr Dre Easy E DJ yella and MC Ren
navigate their way through the industry
acquiring fame fortune and a place in
history starring O'Shea Jackson Jr Corey
Hawkins Jason Mitchell and directed by F
Gary gray critics say Straight Outta
Compton is a biopic that's built to last
thanks to F Gary Gray's confident
Direction and engaging performances from
a solid cast this dope gang took my
cutting too
found him in a truck car
[ __ ] copy man
like
this
man don't talk like that man
it could have happened in another way
you can't blame yourself for that Drake
No Tyree gonna always be with you no
matter what
real man and we always gonna be with you
you always gonna be brothers
we're here all right
good Drake we are here together
number six Amadeus
Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart is a remarkably
talented young Viennese composer who
unwittingly finds a fierce rival in the
disciplined and determined Antonio
salieri resenting Mozart for both his
hedonistic lifestyle and his undeniable
Talent the highly religious salieri is
gradually consumed by his jealousy and
becomes obsessed with Mozart's downfall
leading to a devious scheme that has
dire consequences for both men starring
F Marie Abraham Tom Hulse Jeffrey Jones
and directed by me Lois Foreman critics
say Amadeus is a lavish entertaining
powerful film about the life and
influence both positive and negative of
one of Western culture's great artists
[Applause]
I beg you
ah
Mozart Majesty ah no please please it's
not a holy Relic
you know we have met before In This Very
Room
perhaps you don't remember it you were
only six years old he was giving the
most delightful concert here as he got
off the stool he slipped and fell my own
sister Antoinette helped him up and you
know what he did he jumped into her arms
and said will you marry me yes or no
[Laughter]
candelabra
world famous pianist Liberace takes much
younger Scott Thorson as a lover but the
relationship deteriorates when Liberace
takes other bedmates and Thorson becomes
addicted to drugs starring Michael
Douglas Matt Damon Dan Aykroyd and
directed by Stephen Soderberg critics
say affectionate without sacrificing
honesty Behind the Candelabra couple's
award-worthy performances from Michael
Douglas and Matt Damon with some
typically sharp direction from Steven
Soderberg now Jack I want to talk to you
about doing some surgery on Scott here
what
fine what would you like me to do with
Scott
[Applause]
I want you to make Scott look like this
can you do that
oh I see oh yes I think I can do what
you want
he's gonna need another job
and I'm gonna have to restructure his
cheekbones and his chin with silicone
implants but it's not impossible but
first
we gotta slim him down I have a terrific
diet the California diet guaranteed loss
of 15 pounds in four weeks
Number Four The Pianist
in this adaptation of the autobiography
The Pianist the extraordinary true story
of one man's survival in Warsaw
1939-1945. Lottie slaw Spillman a Polish
Jewish radio station pianist sees Warsaw
change gradually as World War II begins
Spillman is forced into the Warsaw
Ghetto but is later separated from his
family during Operation Reinhard from
this time until the Concentration Camp
prisoners are released Spillman hides in
various locations among the ruins of
Warsaw starring Adrian Brody Thomas
kressman Frank find Finlay and directed
by Roman Polanski critics say well acted
and dramatically moving The Pianist is
polanski's best work in years
are you from the slide
you're not registered it belongs to a
friend of mine
came to visit me
have you got your identity card
let me see your identity card
I want to see our identity cards what's
happening he's a tune
[Applause]
don't let it out
foreign
midnight
in the 1950s Dale Turner A Gifted black
saxophonist with a drinking problem
leaves behind New York and his estranged
family and relocates to Paris there he
plays for a Progressive Jazz loving
audience without being judged by his
race and ages quietly in peace not
intending to turn away from his vices
Dale nonetheless becomes a project of a
French fan who tries to help him fight
his alcoholism ultimately inspiring both
Dale and his music starring Dexter
Gordon Francois cluse Gabrielle hacker
and directed by pertan Tavernier critics
say brought brilliantly to life by
Dexter Gordon's outstanding performance
round midnight is the rare Jazz
inflected drama that matches the power
of music
foreign
I wrote for my daughter
Chan who says 10 15.
14.
10 so
number two What's Love Got to Do with It
based on the life of the legendary soul
singer Tina Turner discovers her love of
singing in her Tennessee church choir
she moves to St Louis to pursue a career
and there she meets the charismatic Ike
Turner who re-christens her Tina and
offers to help her succeed as a musical
team Ike and Tina take the charts by
storm but as his physical abuse worsens
Tina has to make the tough decision to
leave Ike and set out on her own
starring Angela Bassett Lawrence
Fishburne Vanessa Bell Calloway and
directed by Brian Gibson critics say
with a fascinating real life story and
Powerhouse performances from Angela
Bassett and Lawrence Fishburne What's
Love Got to Do With It is a can't miss
biopic
come on what's the matter baby you high
you embarrassing oh come on
white man has to open the mouth she's
singing I asked you ain't gonna say no
no
anime
stay good
how to make come on let's get real good
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Selena
in this biographical drama Selena
Quintanilla is born into a musical
Mexican-American family in Texas her
father Abraham realizes that his young
daughter is talented and begins
performing with her at small venues she
finds success and falls for her
guitarist Chris Perez who draws the ire
of her father seeking mainstream stardom
Selena begins recording in English
language album which tragically she
could never complete starring Jennifer
Lopez Edward James Olmos John SATA and
directed by Gregory Nava critics say
Selena occasionally struggles to tell
its subject story with depth or
perspective but those flaws are rendered
largely irrelevant by Jennifer Lopez in
the title role
can't believe this son what were you
thinking
I can't believe this son
what were you thinking of
where are you
who's that laugh is that Selena
listen where are you so he didn't care
about his bum bro ah that he was happy
you should have seen these two big tough
looking cholos that right Joe Yeah man
they had tattoos and goatees yeah man he
wanted to hang his Bumper in his garage
oh he got like a shrine yeah he was like
anything for Selena I mean not Selena
but Salina to the nest it was weird he
didn't let me pay for it he was like he
was happy to have his bumper taken off
by our bus or by Selena says yes
[Music]
anything foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the people of Detroit know Eight Mile as
the city limit a border a boundary it is
also a psychological dividing line that
separates Jimmy Smith Jr from where and
who he wants to be a provocative
fictional examination of a critical week
in Jimmy's life starring Eminem Kim
Basinger Brittany Murphy and directed by
Curtis Hanson critics say even though
the story is overly familiar in Eight
Mile there's enough here for an engaging
ride
it's almost beautiful
you know when I was little I used to
want to live in a house like this
I don't know how it used to be
you live with your family
I got out of there as quick as I could
left home when I was 17.
we got you
sort of the same
when you record your demo
I'd really love to be there
you're gonna be great
I got a feeling about you
see ya
see ya
Walk the Line
the rise of country music legend Johnny
Cash begins with his days as a boy
growing up on the Family Farm where he
struggles under the scorn of his father
as the years pass cash ends up in
Memphis Tennessee with his wife Vivian
and breaks into the music scene after
finding his trademark sound while on
tour cash meets the love of his life
singer June Carter but Cash's volatile
lifestyle threatens to keep them apart
starring Joaquin Phoenix Reese
Witherspoon Jennifer Goodwin and
directed by James Mangold critics say
Superior acting and authentic crooning
capture the emotional subtleties of the
legend of Johnny Cash and walk the line
with a freshness that is a pleasure to
watch
come on dude just come have a beer with
us
I'm going home tonight after the show
I'm not here to look after y'all
you're not
[Music]
you got somebody to do that for you John
you got a wife somewhere you remember
that
what if I didn't
there's too many F's in that sense only
one actually
there's only one if in that sentence
June
that's always a good point there's only
one really
okay
what was I thinking I must have been
crazy
y'all gonna blow this tour
you can't walk no line
you didn't win blowing the tour I am not
gonna beat that little Dutch boy with my
finger in the dam no more
and finally number one The Buddy Holly
Story
a Chronicle of the rise and brief career
of rock and roll star Buddy Holly who
aspires to play music the way he wants
it to sound Holly and his band The
Crickets are first invited to record in
Nashville where they encounter creative
differences with the producing staff
later they play a major booking at the
Apollo Theater scheduled there under the
mistaken assumption that they're a black
band Holly's career eventually goes solo
until the tragic day the music dies
starring Gary Busey Don Strode Charles
Martin Smith and directed by Steve rash
Gary Arnold from Washington Post says
The Buddy Holly Story is an entertaining
Chronicle of Holly's brief but
productive and influential career as a
pioneering rock and roll composer and
singer hell they don't even allow drums
in the Grand old Opry we're not country
players why you have a country band
playing behind us because there ain't no
such thing as a hit record with just
three guys playing in any kind of music
that's just it we've arranged it so a
small group will sound as good as a big
one you call me up Monday and you said
let's get down here and make some
records fast while I'm here in this is
what we've done now what do you call it
probably a mistake buddy
well
I guess that tears it hot shot
now
why don't you get your loving ass right
back out there where you belong
come on baby come on
let's get the hell back to the
Laboratories
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]